comment on vient agent secret c'est vrai
que déjà c'est comment ça se passe alors
en France tu as déjà c'est une grosse
entreprise il y a à peu près aujourd'hui
à peu près 7000 personnes il y a deux
tiers de civils un tiers de militaires
donc les civils c'est sur concours il y
a toutes les catégories dans le ABC et
après il y a des postes qui sont ouverts
il y a des concours
ici par exemple pour avoir un agent
secret on le saurait pas je crois que
dit qu'il vient de partir de Secret
Story
et après quand on est militaire c'est
c'est une demande on fait une demande
officielle et ensuite on suit le cursus
il y a des tests écrits il y a des tests
psy après etc etc ceux qui sont retenus
passent sont affectés dans les
différents sens de du service action de
la DGSE ou à la DGSE et ensuite il y a
une longue formation qui va durer six
mois un an en fonction des postes qu'on
cherche alors c'est quoi une journée
type quand on agent secret c'est quoi et
bien ça dépend si on est en mission et
bien en général j'avais que des missions
de surveillance pour monter des dossiers
actions sur c'était la période avant le
11 septembre et juste au moment du 11
septembre donc c'était surtout pour
monter des dossiers pour potentiellement
éliminer des gens c'est les fameux
opérations homo qu'on entend dans ton
entende parler régulièrement et donc une
journée type en mission c'est soit on
fait de l'observation humaine soit on
fait de la filature si on fait de la
photo si on fait de la vidéo et de façon
à avoir tous les renseignements qu'on
peut avoir sur une personne sur cette
personne là c'est la cible en question
et ensuite et bien après ça suit ça suit
le le le cheminement et
si les politiques donnent le feu vert
cette personne-là est éliminée quoi
donc vos missions c'était ça donc
essayez de repérer moi je faisais partie
d'une cellule clandestine qui préparait
qui était l'avant dernière cellule on
faisait une on faisait ce qu'on appelle
de durant saignement afin d'action de
façon à pouvoir avoir
en recherche en chercher l'habitude une
habitude sur l'individu pour qu'on
puisse soit l'éliminer de façon avec de
l'explosif sous sa voiture par exemple
mais une habitude c'est sur une longue
distance c'est un point un point B tous
les jours pendant x mois et on avait une
on avait comme on dirait une
obligation c'est qu'il soit seul pas de
femme pas d'enfants
la faisabilité de l'action et après il y
avait action ou pas ça on savait pas
alors
il y a eu un dans votre livre vous avez
aucun moment marquant votre carrière
d'agent secret vous avez été kidnappé en
Libye lors d'une mission spéciale
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé alors
je précise qu'en Libye j'étais plus au
service Action j'étais dans le dans une
société de renseignements privés et
j'étais en Libye au moment du du juste
après le début du conflit donc c'était
en 2011 en avril 2011 et en mai 2011 on
a été enlevé par une Cathy boy une Cathy
by islamiste parce qu'elle pensait qu'on
était venu les espionner au profit de
Kadhafi ce qui était en partie vrai
maintenant je peux le dire et donc on a
été enlevé ils ont on a été enlevé dans
une rue sombre un soir arrêtée ils ont
tué mon copain à côté de moi et ensuite
on a eu 15 jours de été combien on était
cinq on était trois au départ de son
sont venus pour par la suite pierre
margalis celui qui a été tué et d'autres
personnes et donc ce soir là on a été
ils nous sont tombés dessus c'est une
vingtaine armée cagoulée ils ont tué
pierre donc à côté on était allongé sur
le sur le sable les mains derrière la
tête il le tue ensuite on est on est
amené dans
une sorte de prison quelques kilomètres
plus loin et là on a eu 15 jours de
vacances forcément c'était quoi les il y
a eu beaucoup de simulacres d'exécution
de torture de coûts
des simulateurs les tortues les tortures
les plus efficaces et les plus
dangereuses à long terme sur l'individu
c'est les simulaces d'exécution par
exemple avec un pistolet sur la tempe
donc ça vous en avez beaucoup c'était
régulier finalement et vous n'avez pas
été exécuté qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
comment alors on n'a pas été parce que
paradoxalement faut savoir à cette
période là je pense que la France aidait
les rebelles anti Kadhafi mais ces
rebelles anti Kadhafi ils étaient assez
infiltré on va dire officiellement par
par des réseaux islamistes et puis par
certains pays
du golf
donc ils étaient un peu emmerdés parce
qu'il était né de français ils veulent
tuer un français mais la France les
aidait donc qui ils nous ont pas libéré
les Français sont nous ont pas libérés
en revanche ils nous ont expulsés bon il
y a eu il y a pas eu il y a pas eu de
rançon il y a pas eu on va dire qu'on
n'était pas au stage comme on a pu le
voir avec certains journalistes dans
certains pays où là c'était vraiment
encore je pense que dans notre malheur
on a eu un peu de chance mais bon après
c'est on l'a enfin je veux dire personne
nous a obligé d'aller là-bas c'est pas
un bouquin pour dénoncer quoi que ce
soit c'est surtout pour rendre hommage à
Pierre mensiali qui a été tué à côté de
moi
pour plein de gens un agent secret c'est
vrai qu'il y a plein de mystères les
gens voilà c'est bien du monde c'est
Daniel Craig mais c'est vrai que si
est-ce que vous gardez votre vrai prénom
votre prénom ce que vous appeliez pierre
Martini non pas du tout on s'appelait
même au quotidien on était on avait des
pseudos ah ouais donc au quotidien moi
je m'appelle Florent pour totalement
démarquer la vie
Florence ça passe partout en Afrique
déjà ça c'était un pseudo quotidien
quand je partais en mission j'avais une
un autre prénom et un autre nom c'était
quoi Vincent Sadan d'accord
vous aviez le le passeport tout vous
aviez la légende ce qu'on appelle la
légende absolument ça on avait peut-être
vu le bureau des légendes aussi donc on
a on avait on avait une petite par
rapport au bureau des légendes cette
partie là est similaire donc dès qu'on
arrivait à Paris on allait à la sécurité
on arrive avec notre vraie vie on
déposait notre vraie vie si on avait des
alliances et on prenait la fausse vie
c'est-à-dire carte bancaire
la clé de l'appartement qu'on avait
aussi
oui non j'ai déjà ton autorisation
est-ce que on peut avoir une vie de
famille quand on est alors oui j'avais
une oui moi j'avais une vie de famille
parce que ma femme était aussi agent
quoi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
dans le film là avec la totale
exactement
et vous vous le savez
vous étiez agent
parfois ensemble
parce que on était tellement on
s'appelait plus par nos pseudos que par
nos prénoms réels
on peut pas le dire en fait la plupart
c'est pour ça c'est particulière on
faisait quoi vos potes j'étais
moniteur de parachutisme dans l'armée ah
ouais d'accord
mais on peut pas en fait c'est une vie
particulière parce que on n'a pas le
droit de dire ce qu'on fait ni à ses
voisins ni à ses amis
surtout pas sa famille et ouais ça
c'était à Orléans et on n'a pas le droit
de parler de ce qu'on fait donc on
s'invente une légende aussi dans le dans
la dans la vie privée une fois et c'est
pour ça qu'on vit en autarcie on vit
tous on se reçoit les uns les autres de
la semaine on est ensemble le week-end
on est ensemble et finalement c'est une
vie assez particulière parce que on a
pas d'ouverture sur la sur le monde en
fait même si on est dans une vie où on
est plus militaire on travaille en civil
on a des on peut faire des stages dans
le privé pour pour éventuellement
partir ou s'infiltrer dans certaines
sociétés mais c'est une vie particulière
parce qu'on vit en autarcie on n'a pas
vraiment de c'est pour ça qu'on j'y vais
pas rester si longtemps que ça j'ai fait
que 5 ans 20 ans en total mais 5 ans
c'est vachement bien payé
en fait c'est absolument pas payé non on
est payant en fonction du grade qu'on
avait grosso modo je devrais en fin de
carrière je devais gagner hors prime je
devais gagner 3000 euros net par mois
on risque pas plus notre vie que ceux
qui partent au Mali ceux qui partent en
Afghanistan c'est bien de le dire quand
j'étais au service Action j'ai moins
risqué ma vie que quand j'étais pendant
hier du Tchad du Liban etc alors on va
faire deux trois questions intelligentes
questions vous dites qu'effectivement
donc on suit des gens et puis ensuite
pour les éliminer peut-être en explosant
les voitures ça ça arrive dans depuis
est-ce que ça peut arriver ça à Paris ou
dans des grandes villes de France qu'on
élimine à voilà un ennemi en pigeant sa
voiture en plein en plein centre-ville
alors en théorie non parce que le
service action a des GSE c'est extérieur
mais je peux pas dire que ça n'existe
pas je peux pas dire que ça n'existe pas
mais je peux pas dire que ça existe je
n'en sais rien mais j'ai travaillé en
France moi sur un une target en France
j'ai travaillé en France sur une cible
Serbe qui était à cette période on
travaillait sur recherche de criminels
de guerre autour de
des criminels de guerre de lecture
Australie d'accord et donc on avait
quelqu'un qui était en France donc on a
travaillé sur en France
non non là c'était pas pour l'éliminer
c'est pour remonter un parasite qui
était qui était on sait pas où il était
justement donc on essaie de trouver des
ficelles pour remonter à lui d'accord
très tranquille en France à quel moment
on se dit je vais partir dans un pays en
crise qui est en pleine guerre civile
en fait à cette période j'étais dans une
société où j'avais j'étais manager je
gérais pas mal de personnes et je
m'emmerdais en fait je me fais ouais je
vais m'emmerdais donc je me suis dit bon
je
à cette période de la Libye il y avait
pas mal de printemps arabe avait
commencé et j'ai passé deux trois coups
de fil pour réintégrer une structure
comme ça parce que
malgré tout l'adrénaline de des pays en
guerre ça une fois qu'on y a goûté ça ça
peut pas s'emper c'est une drogue et
vous avez une question Béatrice vous
voyez ce que quelqu'un comme moi avec
une double nationalité pourrait être
recruté par moitié américain moitié
française
donc ça pose pas
on sait pas
oui mais c'est on en avait eu on en
avait un comme ça qui était
franco-américain
et pourquoi ça a posé un problème
loyauté loyauté c'est ça après ça pose
problème
bien sûr
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
oui est-ce que vous avez des des gadgets
comme dans les films alors on a des
gadgets mais la difficulté c'était
franchir les frontières avec les avec le
matos donc on avait le minimum possible
de gadgets parfois on est arrivé à
passer des trucs dans des postes radio
qui était qui était aménagés par une
cellule spéciale comme dans James Bond
le fameux cue là
on avait une cellule comme ça avec des
gens qui qui nous fabriquaient deux
trois bricoles mais c'était vraiment
très succinct parce que on avait des
frontières à passer
[Rires]
la mission la plus folle que vous ayez
fait alors je vais vous décevoir mais il
y a pas de mission folle en fait c'est
très académique et très procédurier
vraiment c'est c'est incroyablement
[Musique]
il y a beaucoup de dossiers de
préparation de dossier en amont il y a
beaucoup de dossiers après
et si bien qu'à un moment on appelait ça
le service administratif au lieu
d'appeler le service d'action parce que
c'est très français ça faut savoir qu'en
France quel que soit l'administration
dans laquelle on travaille on a plus de
préparation dans un bureau que d'action
on passe ton temps à préparer mais
l'action est très est très courte après
c'est intéressant parce que ce qui est
intéressant cette franchir des
frontières à l'époque je suis parti en
mission en mission seule en axe
dans un pays de l'est donc voilà c'est
c'est l'excitation de passer des
frontières avec des faux passeports
enfin des vrais faux passeports et de se
retrouver seul dans des pays comme ça en
avec une mission particulière très
intelligente c'est la dernière la
deuxième non est-ce qu'il y a déjà des
puissances étrangères qui ont essayé de
vous retourner ou de vous faire
travailler ou est-ce que vous avez des
collègues qui ont été approchés et qui
ont trahi alors oui il y a eu des des
collègues qui ont été approchés dans je
crois du côté de la Bretagne les nageurs
de combat je crois qu'il y a eu une
période comme ça et je crois aussi que
c'était par l'intermédiaire des épouses
voilà ah oui mais il y a eu aussi vous
savez avec tout ce qui est sport là
l'estravail et tout c'est tout ce qu'on
peut suivre là aussi il y a eu des des
trucs comme ça que mais en ce qui me
concerne non parce que on avait aucun
contact avec des puissances étrangères
puisque déjà on allait dans les pays
amis de façon clandestine donc personne
était au courant et c'est ce que je
raconte dans mon premier livre et ça ça
fait scandale parce que
j'avais pas le droit de la question
intelligente elle est très courte
psychologiquement quand vous étiez les
cinq au sol et que vous entendez que
votre ami dans la tête d'abord vous vous
dites c'est bon c'est pour moi vous
allez mourir et même psychologiquement
après il y a des cellules comment vous
avez fait
en fait quand ça s'est passé tellement
vite que je comprenais pas ce qui se
passait et je me suis retrouvé donc
allongé sur le sol les mains sur la sur
la nuque dans le sable et j'avais la
tête autour de tourner à gauche parce
que je peux pas rester la tête je le
mets dans le sable et Pierre qui était à
ma gauche prend une balle vous le voyez
oui je le vois prendre une balle il part
dans un ralent tout de suite je sens que
c'est et moi pour moi c'était une
exécution et donc j'ai fermé les yeux
j'ai attendu d'en prendre une
j'ai juste eu le temps de voir des
inscriptions en arabe sur les sur les
sur le pick-up qui avait qui avait
devant moi mais j'étais là pour moi ça
s'est arrêté là quoi d'accord dans une
rue sombre de benghai aujourd'hui vous
vous continuez cette activité alors
aujourd'hui j'ai ce que je vis à Londres
un peu enfin j'ai vécu à Londres pendant
5 ans là j'ai un pied à Londres un pied
en France et j'ai une société qui
s'appelle winkorp security défense et je
fais de la formation
je fais de la formation mais pour les
états surtout pour les Africains parce
que moi j'aime bien l'Afrique je vais
souvent du jeu en Afrique depuis 1983
mais cette activité
en partie je continue je continue à la
voir parce qu'on peut faire aussi du
renseignement ou faire de la formation
pour du renseignements est-ce que vous
les faites encore ou vous avez arrêté
après ce qui s'est passé alors après ce
qui s'est passé j'ai mis un peu de temps
à retourner dans un pays et quand je
suis retourné à l'étranger c'était pour
débriefer quelqu'un qui avait été enlevé
à Madagascar comme toi bah j'avais un
peu de d'appréhension alors Lucas
l'estimation du nombre d'agences secrets
qui est en France c'est dingue parce que
c'est lui qui pose les meilleures
questions il a raison on en a combien
c'est une bonne question alors au
service action c'est vraiment un petit
service de la DGSE qui est au sein de la
Direction des Opérations c'est un
service avec je vais essayer de d'être
relativement précis je pense que
150 150 agents mais faut savoir que pour
150 agents il y a le double trip de
soutien en fait il y a le ça au service
action il y a le on n'est rien sur le
soutien et le soutien ne servirait à
rien s'il y a pas les opérationnel c'est
vraiment une chaîne une chaîne où chaque
maillon est importante celui qui celui
qui fait qui fait à manger ou celui qui
nettoie ou celui qui fait du gardiennage
est aussi important que l'agent donc on
est vraiment une famille et on doit être
opérationnel au sein du Service Action
je pense 150 dans le domaine de la
sécurité dans lequel vous bossez il y a
quand même des ambiguïtés les sociétés
de sécurité parfois on dit c'est des
barbouzes ou des mercenaires est-ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec ça est-ce que
vous-même vous l'êtes alors oui non oui
non parce que non mais la question est
très bonne parce que justement en ce
moment on parle souvent de Wagner
c'est une question pertinente parce que
parce qu'on parle souvent de Wagner
alors que Wagner n'a rien à voir avec
nous il faut vraiment pas faire
d'amalgame entre un mot à la mode entre
Wagner et les sociétés privées notamment
françaises ou anglo-saxonnes parce que
Wagner ce n'est pas une société privée
parce que en Russie les sociétés privées
n'ont pas d'existence légale c'est pour
ça que le siège social je crois qui est
en Amérique du Sud et Wagner c'est pas
une société privée c'est l'armée c'est
une extension de l'armée russe d'accord
une société privée comme la mienne ou
comme dans d'autres en France et dans
d'autres pays on passe des contrats on
passe des contrats avec des états on
passe des contrats en général c'est avec
des États ou des grosses sociétés et
tout est carré en fait il y a pas de pas
d'ambiguïté justement après
barbouz c'est un terme qui est qui vous
devez le savoir certainement c'est un
vieux terme qui date du sac etc barbouze
ben oui dès l'instant on sort un peu des
clous bon on est bas on est on est
catalogué comme barbouze par les
journalistes français parce que c'est
très français barbouze ça n'existe pas
ailleurs et oui j'ai été catalogué comme
un bar mousse parce que quand j'ai fait
des conneries c'est des trucs je fais
quelques conneries que j'étais j'ai été
condamné pour ça donc la ligne la ligne
la ligne blanche est facilement
Mathieu qui qui
j'ai fait ce qu'on appelle une
surveillance interdite et c'est cette
dérive là qu'il faut pas qu'il faut
éviter de faire quand on est quand on
passe dans le privé et pour ça il faut
vraiment préparer sa sortie parce que du
jour au lendemain quand on passe dans le
privé et qu'on fait la même chose dans
le privé que dans le truc on sait plus
on sait plus trop on habite quoi
en ce qui me concerne tout le monde ne
fait pas ça bien sûr Sophie dans votre
livre vous dites en fait que vous avez
fait ce métier là à la base parce que
vous étiez romanesque parce que vous
étiez chevaleresque vous parlez des
femmes des conquêtes etc vous avez
remercié non mais vous remercier les
femmes que vous avez rencontrées vous
avez connu etc etc donc je me suis posé
la question de savoir en fait ce qu'on
pense à James Bond il y a un côté quand
même assez sexy chez les agents non mais
c'est vrai il y a quelque chose comme ça
est-ce que vous avez jamais rencontré
finalement une espèce de Matahari qui
vous a fait dévier un petit peu non il y
a pas eu cette idée d'histoires
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
en fait
quand j'étais quand j'étais au service
quand j'étais au service il y a pas de
femme il y a pas de fin j'ai pas de
femme quand on est en mission il y a pas
de femme pour la personne oui parce que
c'était en dehors mais j'ai plus
rencontré quand j'ai fait mon premier
livre parce que je révèle mon parcours
effectivement alors agent secret c'est
pas le terme qu'on emploie c'est un
terme c'est un terme de cinéma mais
quand on connaît le métier ce qui se
passe dans James Bond c'est l'Antiquité
[Applaudissements]
merci mon chéri